why's women
leave motivation family believe me
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you you've
got Michael Jordan level talent at
something so get ready to work super
hard have a great product and attract
great people with Elon Musk and my take
on his top 50 rules for success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one no work super hard if anyone
helped well you want to do particularly
if you're starting a company you need to
work super hard so what is super hard
mean well when my brother and I were
studying our first company instead of
getting an apartment we just rented us a
small office and we slept on the couch
and we showered at the YMCA and we're so
hot up we had one computer so the
website was up during the day and I was
coding at night seven days a week all
the time and I sort of briefly had a
girlfriend in that period and in order
to deal with me she have to sleep in the
office so I work hard like and it mean
every waking hour that's that's the the
thing I would I would say if you're
particularly if you're starting a
company and I mean if you do simple math
to say like okay if somebody else is
working 50 hours and you're working 100
you'll get twice as done as much done in
the course of a year as as the other
company rule number two have a great
product you could make sure that
whatever you're doing is a great product
or service it has to be really great and
I go back to what I was saying earlier
where if you're a new company I mean
this it's like some new industry or new
market that if it's an untapped market
or then then you have more ability to
give is this the standard is lower for
your product or service but if you're
entering anything where there's an
existing market place against Lodge
entrenched
redditors then your product or service
needs to be much better than theirs it
can't be a little bit better because
then you put yourself in the shoes of
the consumer and they say why would you
buy it as a consumer you're always gonna
bribe the trusted brand unless there's a
big difference so a lot of times you
know entrepreneur will come up with
something which is only slightly better
and it's it's not you can't just be
slightly better it's gotta be a lot
better rule number three attract great
people if you're creating company or if
you're joining a company the most
important thing is to attract is to
attract great people so either be would
join a group that's amazing that you've
really respect or if you've building a
company you've got to gather great
people I mean all the company is is a
group of people that have gathered
together to create a product or service
and so depending upon how talented and
hardworking that group is and the
greeter which they are focused
cohesively in a good direction that will
determine the success of the company
so do everything you can to to gather
great people if you're creating a
company rule number four look for
problem solvers
when interview someone to work the
companies would be to ask me tell me
about the problems that they worked on
and how they sold them and if someone
was really the person that solved it
they'll be able to answer multiple
levels they'll be able to go down to the
brass tacks and if they would they'll
get stuck and then you can say oh this
person was not really the person who
solved it because anyone who struggled
hard with a problem never forgets it
also if you want to have more confidence
check out my 254 series it's free the
link to join is in the description below
there are times when something is
important enough you believe in it
enough that you do you do it in spite of
the fear rule number five focus on
signal over noise focus on on signal
over noise a lot of companies get
confused they they spend money on things
that don't actually make the product
better for example at Tesla
we've we've never spent any money on
appetising we put all of the money into
R&D and manufacturing and design to try
to make the car as good as possible
and I think that's that's the way to go
before for any given company just keep
thinking about are these efforts that
people are expending are they resulting
in a better product or service and if
they're not stop those efforts rule
number six do something important how
did you figure you were gonna start a
car company and be successful at it well
I didn't really think Tesla would be
successful I thought we would most
likely fail but I thought that we at
least could address the false perception
that people had that an electric car had
to be ugly and slow and and boring like
a golf cart but you say you didn't
expect the company be successful and why
try if something is important enough you
should try even if you probable outcome
is failure
rule number seven take a risk now is the
time to take risk you don't have kids as
you get older your obligations increase
so your and once you have a family you
start taking risk not just for yourself
but for your family as well it gets much
harder to do things that might not work
out so now is the time to do that before
you before you have those obligations so
I would encourage you to take risks now
it be something bold
you want to regret it well number eight
don't listen to the little man so many
people try to talk me out of starting a
road company it was it was crazy one
good friend of mine collected a whole
series of videos of rockets blowing up
and maybe watch those you just didn't
want me to lose all my money we're doing
these things that seem unlikely to
succeed and we've been fortunate and at
least thus far they have succeeded rule
number nine really like what you do
really liking what you do whatever area
that you get into given that you know
even if you if you're the best the best
there's always a chance of failure so I
think it's important that you really
like whatever you're doing if you don't
like it life is too short if you like
what you're doing you think about it
even when you're not working I mean
it'll just it's it's something that your
mind is drawn to and and if you don't
like it you just really can't make it
work I think rule number ten never
give up that third failure in a row did
you think I need to pack this in ever
why not I don't ever give up I'd have to
be dead or completely incapacitated rule
number 11 act despite fear or unusually
fearless and willing to go in the face
of other people telling you something
that's crazy and I know a lot of pretty
crazy people you still stand out where
does that come from or how do you think
about making a decision when everyone
tells you this is a crazy idea where do
you get the internal strength to do that
well first of all I'd say I actually
think I feel feel fear quite strongly so
it's not as though I just have the
absence of fear I've I feel it quite
strongly but there are times when
something is important enough you
believe it enough that you do you do it
in spite of fear so speaking of
important things like people shouldn't
think III I should if you should think
well I feel fear about this and
therefore I shouldn't do it it's normal
to be to feel fear like you'd have to do
something mentally wrong you shouldn't
feel fear
so you just feel it and let the
importance of it drive you to do it
anyway yeah you know actually we're
something that can be helpful as
fatalism some degree if you just think
if just accept the probabilities then
that diminishes fear so we're starting
SpaceX I thought the odds of success
were less than 10% and I just accepted
that actually probably I would just lose
lose everything but that maybe would
make some progress if we could just move
the ball forward even if we died maybe
some other company could pick up the
baton and move and keep moving it
forward so that were still do some good
yeah same with Tesla I thought your odds
of a car company succeeding were
extremely low rule number 12 focus on
the customers I would definitely advise
people there's not any company to expect
a a long period of quite high difficulty
yeah but that means long as people stake
super focused on creating an absolute
best product or service that really
delights their end customer like if they
stay focused on that then it should
basically if you get a search that your
customers want you to succeed then you
probably will all right you have to
focus on the customer delivering for
them yeah
make sure if your customers w you will
your odds of success are dramatically
higher rule number 13 have a high pain
threshold one does have to be focused on
we're short Tim and money coming in when
creating company because otherwise the
company will die so that I think that a
lot of times people think like creating
company is gonna be fun I would say it's
not it's really not that fun I mean
there are periods of fun and there are
periods of where to where she's awful
and particularly if you CEO of the
company
you actually have a distillation of all
the worst problems in a company there's
no point in spending your time on things
that are going right so you only spend
on things on your time on things that
are going wrong and and there are things
that are going wrong that other people
can't can't take care of so you're like
the worst you have a filter for the
crappers problems in the company the
most pernicious and painful problem so I
wouldn't say it's it's I think you have
to feel quite compelled to do it and
have a fairly high pain threshold and
there's a friend of mine who says like
starting companies like staring at the
abyss and eating glass and there's some
truth to that we're starting to the best
part is that you're gonna be constantly
facing the extermination of the company
because most most startups fail yeah
it's like 90 percent
luckily 99 percent of startups fail so I
so you that that's the staring into the
abyss part you can't stir constantly
saying okay if I don't get this right
the company will die should be quite
rightful quite stressful and and then
the eating glass part is you've got
you've got to do you've got to do the
problems you gonna so you're gonna work
on the problems that the company needs
you to work on not
she want to work on and so that the
that's you and I've working on problems
that that you'd really wish you weren't
working on okay so that's the eating
glass part then that goes on for a long
time so how do you keep your focus on
the big picture when you're constantly
faced with we could be out of business
in a month well it's just a very small
percentage of mental energies on the on
the big picture like you know you know
you know where you generally heading for
and and the actual path is gonna be some
sort of zigzagging thing in that
direction and try not to deviate too far
from the path that that you want to be
on but you're gonna have to do that some
degree but I don't wanna I don't to
diminish the I mean I think the product
the profit motive is it is a is a good
one if the rules of an industry are
properly set up so there's something
fundamentally wrong with puppet in fact
profit just means that people are paying
you more for the that whatever you're
doing then you're spending to create it
that's a good thing and if you're not if
that's not the case then you'll be out
of business and rightfully so sure
you're not adding enough value rule
number fourteen be rigorous and self
analysis first why I really taken some
thoughts like how can I provide advice
that would be most helpful and I'm not
sure I've given enough thought to to
that to give you the best possible
answer but I think I think certainly
being focused on something that you're
confident will have high value to
someone else and just being really
rigorous in making that assessment
because people are attend tend to
natural human tendency is wishful
thinking so a challenge for
entrepreneurs is to say well what's the
difference between really believing in
new ideals and sticking sticking to them
versus pursuing some unrealistic dream
that doesn't actually have merit and
it's it's that is it that is a really
difficult thing to to tell you can you
tell the difference between those two
things
yeah so you need to be sort of very
rigorous
in yourself self-analysis I think
certainly extremely tenacious and and
then just work like hell I mean you just
have to put in you know 80 hour 80 100
hour weeks every week and then I like
that but all those things improve the
odds of success okay
I mean if other people are putting in 40
hour work weeks and you're putting in
100 hour work weeks then even if you're
doing the same thing you know that in
one year you will achieve what they
achieve you will achieve in four months
what it takes them a year to achieve
rule number 15 expect to fail so
failures are not the most terrible
things whether you have to learn from it
and react to it yeah exactly when you're
building something new there's going to
be mistakes and it's important to to
recognize those mistakes acknowledge
them and take corrective action yeah and
the successful company is very much more
about how quick are you to fix the
mistakes not will you make mistakes or
admit mistakes yeah absolutely yeah and
if you see the difference between a
startup that is successful in one that
is not and it's because the successful
one they're both made mistakes but the
successful one recognized the mistakes
fix them very quickly and the the
unsuccessful one tries to deny that the
mistakes exist you know extremely smart
people are sometimes quite arrogant
because they believe in what they
believe in right and so the way they
face criticism it's less likely to admit
you know they can make mistakes was that
in your case I learnt it when I was
doing when I was studying physics at the
the you know in physics you're taught to
always question yourself you're taught
to always assume that you're wrong not
to seem that you're right and you have
to prove yourself not not wrong and so I
think that that that physics framework
is really where where I learnt it and
it's very effective for wonderful
learning counterintuitive things that
aren't obvious mmm-hmm so you are very
famous in saying that failure is
actually an option and if you're not
failing like that means you're not
innovative
yeah it's not like I like failure man
who likes Billy was terrible but if you
only do things that are certain to
succeed then you're only going to be
doing very obvious things you number-16
have a sense of humor question that has
been discussed over the past couple of
days should we be considering one trips
one way only trips to Mars what's the
best approach to colonize the planet is
it but what is your review it's not
socially acceptable you think people
will sign up to do it I think it's
plenty of people who sign up for a
warrior to Mars but maybe if I could
just have a show of hands who would
consider such an option I see some not
many or perhaps enough for a couple of
missions
simply be enough I think it's sort of
like is it a one-way mission and then
you die or is this a one-way mission and
you get resupplied that's a big
difference
we're for the second option yeah exactly
but I mean I think it's so it ends up
being a moot point because you want to
bring the spaceship back like these
spaceships are expensive okay if they're
hard to bulls and just leave them there
so whether or not people want to come
back or not is kind of like they can
jump on if they want but they need the
spaceship back thank you I mean kind of
weird like it was like huge collection
of spaceships on Mars over time really
it's like where she's in the back and of
course there's just an event
rule number 17 aim for perfection what
Tesla your goal has been to make a
better car and you've done that with an
electric vehicle that people covet that
has quite a cult following
that's upgradable but you also want to
achieve and your turn of phrase is very
nice
or try to achieve this Platonic ideal of
a car right to reach your affection so
what does the perfect car look like well
I'm gonna do I do use that phrase with
our engineering design team that
aspirationally we're in pursuit of like
ideal of the perfect car and here's what
that looks like actually but it's I want
to try to make every element of the car
as as flawless as possible and they'll
always be you know some degree of
imperfection but try to minimize that
and create a car that is just a landfill
in every way and I think if you do that
then the rest kind of takes care of
itself
rule number 18 do your chores so the
innovation can be very exciting life but
doing business sometimes requires no
assistance and sometimes could be very
boring do you have the same fun from
innovation as from business running a
business
well rather to be just an innovator
engineer instead of a business owner or
runner I mean I'd love to just do
innovation work and just do engineering
but you raise a good point because you
know a lot of life in general any job
there's like you have to do your chores
you know there's no nobody can do that
for you well it's yet I think to be
successful at almost anything you can't
if you have to do the tough stuff and as
well as the enjoyable stuff you have to
do the boring stuff as well as the non
boring stuff and if you don't do your
chores then bad things will happen but
if they don't do the things that they
don't like to do then the company will
be in trouble
yeah like you have to basically be like
it's more fun to cook the meal then to
clean the dishes okay but you need to
clean the dishes yes each of us exactly
rule number 19 be an adventurer 2001
with just destroyed a friend of mine and
you asked me yes what I was gonna do
have to PayPal and I thought well you
know I was wondering like I'd like to
get involved in space but I just didn't
think there's anything I could do as an
individual and but I was curious as to
win we win we NASA would be sending a
team to Mars because that was always
gonna be the thing to do after the moon
I figured that that there be some plan
and I just go to websites and I could
read the you know the schedule then Mars
oh yeah it's like okay 2017 good okay
but actually there wasn't anything on on
the website and or at least I thought
like am I cannot find it like what's
going on right here and it's a secret I
don't know I so but it turned out that
that NASA had done a study on what it
would cost to send to do a manned Mars
mission and I this was under Bush the
first and I suppose he asked for a
90-day study short left a taking office
and NASA came back with a 500 billion
dollar price tag he said okay maybe not
bill you know me that's been 500 billion
dollars was serious money
here for the government so I so then
that got totally shelf and it was like
you were not allowed to talk about any
kind of crude mission to Mars at NASA
anyway so I thought well if I can do
something that word galvanized public
interest that and and then that public
interest would translate to additional
appropriations for NASA increased that
their budget then then maybe they could
do it so the foot so actually what I
sort of thinking I would do is sand as a
small greenhouse the surface of Mars
versed's and dehydrated gel and then
upon landing hydrate the jello go and
and the public has to respond to
precedents and superlatives so this
would be the furthest that life's ever
traveled the first life on Mars I try to
try to figure out how to do this with
the proceeds that I had from from PayPal
and I was able to figure out how to get
the cost of the spacecraft down and the
communications and and and the little of
greenhouse everything but the one thing
I couldn't compress was the cost launch
it was there only a few options and the
us options were way too expensive and
they ended up going to Russia three
times to try to buy the biggest ICBM and
the Russian nuclear fleet
that's where I'd start yeah yeah go big
deal I mean okay but they it was so
there were some strange trips that's for
sure
but you know just like virtually like
you can buy any it's a very capitalist
society some ways so I actually didn't
ago she had a deal to buy two of the
ICBMs minus the nukes
but I can't think inclusion after that
third trip that it would really matter
like you actually came occlusion that my
initial premise was was was wrong
because I actually think there's there's
torrents about a will in the American
population particularly to to explore
the United States
you know maybe more than any other
country is a distillation of the human
spirit of exploration and it's really
fundamental to psyche so if people think
there's a way I think it actually get a
lot of support um but but then it can't
be just banging your head against the
wall I gotta believe that this can be
done without breaking the federal budget
so that's when I said okay well is there
some way to affect the cost of space
transport and and is and so I got
together with a group of people over a
series of Saturdays just to just try to
uh said is there something super expand
'mentally super expensive about rockets
or can the cost be substantially
improved and act had we had a bunch of
those kind of brainstorming sessions and
I couldn't see I couldn't see any
fundamental obstacle to improving the
cost of rockets so that's when I started
SpaceX it's like I'll just build them
myself
yeah and then but I said at that point I
would say the probability of success was
definitely less than 50% I thought it
would most likely not succeed but was
worth a try rule number twenty inspire
greatness as CEO of SpaceX and you've
said that your ultimate goal is to get
humankind to Mars
I've heard your response to the question
but these guys need to hear it why is
Mars important why does Mars matter sure
well I think the it's it's really a
fundamental surgeon we need to make as a
civilization you know what kind of
future do we want do we want a future
where we have forever confined to one
planet until some eventual extinction
event however far in the future that
might occur or do we want to become a
multi-planet species and and then
ultimately be out there among the stars
me among many planets many star systems
and I think the latter is
more exciting and inspiring future than
the former and and Mars is the next
natural step in fact it's the only
planet we really have a shot at at
establishing a self-sustaining city on
and and I think once we do establish
such a city there will be a strong
forcing function for the improvement of
spaceflight technology that will then
enable us to establish colonies
elsewhere in the solar system and
ultimately extend beyond the beyond our
solar system and and so there's the
defensive reason of protecting the
future of humanity ensuring that the
light of consciousness is not
extinguished should some calamity before
earth but also and that's the defensive
reason but personally I find the more
the word what it gets me more excited is
is the fact that this would be an
incredible adventure maybe like the
greatest adventure ever mm-hmm and it
will be exciting and inspiring and they
need to be things that excite and
inspire people yeah you have to be you
know reasons why you get up in the
morning it can't just be solving
problems it's got to be yeah something
something great is gonna happen in the
future yeah we talked about this at
length yesterday it's it's not an exit
strategy or a back-up plan for humankind
or it fails right it's also to inspire
people on earth right and to transcend
and to go beyond our mental limits of
what we think we can achieve all right I
mean I think it helps sort of how
incredible the Apollo program was and
just I mean if if you ask anyone and to
name name some of humanity's greatest
achievements in the 20th century the
Apollo program landing on the moon would
wouldn't it and many if not most places
be number one rule number 21 take risks
one of the most difficult choices I have
ever faced in life was was in 2008 and I
think I had like maybe 30 million
dollars left 30 or 40 dollars left in
2008 I had two choices I could put it
all into one company and then the other
company would definitely die or split it
between the two companies and but if I
split it between two companies then both
might die and you know where you put
your blood sweat and tears into creating
something a bully something it's like a
child
and so it's like which one am I gonna
let one starve to death I can bring
myself to do it surprised I split the
money between two fortunately thank
goodness they both came through rule
number 22 create magic I've heard people
say listen he's out-of-the-box thinker
he's a businessman he's an entrepreneur
I feel that no I wouldn't say you would
say I'm normally a business plan you're
not a businessman no what are you I'm
gonna show there's probably lots of
analysts on Wall Street who agree that
I'm not a businessman okay well what do
you think you are I'm engineer is it
your dream to conquer the world and make
the world a better place - what is your
dream it's like well it's just like
magic
yeah to put I mean I think technology is
the closest thing to magic that we have
in the real world and so I think like
engineering creative engineering is
essentially technology development
Ickes Mavis nice kid I like Lorna rings
is my favorite book is it yeah that's
really like what's the closest thing to
being a wizard in the real world and
that's like creating new technologies
rule number 23 don't rely on wishful
thinking young people globally want to
be like Ella moss what's your advice of
it I think that probably they shouldn't
want to be hey you I think it sounds
better than it is okay
yeah it's not as much fun being me as
you'd think I don't know you don't think
so yeah this definitely it could be
worse for sure but it's I I'm not sure I
would I'm not sure I want to be me but
you know I think advice I mean if you
want to make progress and things I think
that but the the best analytical
framework for us and in the future is
physics
I'd recommend studying the the thinking
process around physics like not just not
the equations I mean equations certainly
they're helpful but the the way of
thinking in physics is the that's the
best framework for understanding things
that are counterintuitive and and you
know always taking the position that you
are some degree wrong and your goal is
to be less wrong over time the one of
the biggest mistakes people generally
make and I'm guilty of a two is wishful
thinking you know like you want
something to be true even if it isn't
true and so you ignore other things that
you ignore the real truth because of
what you want to be true this is a very
difficult trap to avoid and like I said
certainly one that I find myself in
having problems with but if you just
take that approach of your oyster some
degree wrong and your goal is to be less
wrong and and solicit critical feedback
particularly from friends like friends
particular friends if somebody loves you
they want the best for you they don't
want to tell you the bad things so you
have to ask them okay you know it said
really I really do want to know and and
then they will tell you rule number 24
survive failures what was your biggest
failure and how did I change you to
really think hard about that failure
there's your answer
well there's a ton of failures along the
way that's for sure
like I said as I said for for SpaceX the
first three launches failed
and we were just barely able to scrape
together enough parts and money to do
the fourth launch that both launched and
failed we would have been dead so
multiple failures along the way I tried
very hard to get the right expertise in
for for SpaceX I tried hard to to find a
great chief engineer for the rocket but
it but the good chief engineers wouldn't
join and the bad ones well there was no
no point in hiring him so I ended up a
chief engineer at the rocket so if I
could have found somebody better then we
would have maybe had less than three
failures
rule number twenty-five solve big
problems
his interest in our energy crisis
started last year in South Australia a
state already heavily invested in wind
and solar power was plunged into
darkness the result of a massive storm
that saw the state lose power
Elon Musk tweeted headfirst into a
national political brawl when fellow
billionaire Australian IT whiz Mike
cannon Brooks questioned
Tesla's boast that he could help solve
South Australia's energy problems by
building the world's biggest battery why
did you do that
there was no idea of what would happen
afterwards just more if people make big
claims like that I'd like to check if
they're real
you thought I was joking because I had a
checkbook with my team it's like I hope
I I didn't really say something super
crazy when you get a return tweet from
Elon saying yeah what did you think so
wait just checking his kosha yeah he
said he's gonna happen Maggie let's make
it happen
right so this is these are public tweets
yeah and but in a way that's that's part
of our locks in the guarantee right he's
putting his reputation online in a
public forum there that you know enough
noise was then created around enough
people saw that that it was like alright
that you know he'd better get that time
more than ever
Australians are struggling to pay for
their power a record number of families
are on hardship plans or deferred
payments and the rate of disconnections
in most states has risen sharply for
Elon Musk learning of this growing power
poverty is overwhelming cost of power is
making it almost a luxury item Wow
really everybody that I know is that
expensive Australia has so many natural
resources I mean even if you go the
fossil fuel route yeah the electricity
should be very cheap there are
Australians today wondering if they can
even turn on their lights their
Australian stay wondering well should we
go without some food sure in in that's
just not something you would ever expect
I did not expect that hmm
bukata it's necessarily true that we
will live under new renewables it's just
a question of when in fact it's it's
it's it's in the definition that if it's
not renewable that means it's going to
run out at some point and you will have
the choice of collapse of civilization
and instead all gauges we go or find
something that is renewable so all of
this is about saving ourselves yeah
Avilan musk had his way the world would
be totally powered by renewables and
he'd be colonizing Mars he is a
big-picture man with big plans but it
might be his push for the modest lithium
battery will prove to be one of the more
significant steps in this electric
revolution you have been seen as a
catalyst somebody that is showing gosh
the reason there is another way yeah and
that's that's a great thing
people Israelis should be should be
proud of the fact that this trio has the
world's biggest battery this is pretty
great and that it will serve as an
inspiration really to the whole world as
well just to say that this is possible
rule number 26 commit fully this is
widely regarded as one of the most
robotics driven auto assembly lines on
the planet you on one of the thing I
heard about the model threes that
there's too many robots that made me
angry you did you think so too that
maybe you need more people in here
working we do in some cases the robots
actually slowed the production
where this crazy complex network of
conveyor belts and it was not working so
we got rid of that whole thing this is
cool yeah realizing it needed an
overhaul must personally took over the
model 3 production line at the beginning
of April raining for really extreme
levels of precision more than a of
the world he says he has resorted to
pulling all-nighters at the plant I
think so yeah really intense I don't
have time to go home and shower change
side sleep here I wanted to see words
that it's pretty boring really it's
actually cold in here - yeah I like it
cool so you have a you like it cold I
see when they catch her there so you're
just laying here yeah catch yeah last
time as you're actually stepped
literally on the floor because the couch
is too narrow yeah I was gonna say you
know I have to say it's not even a
comfortable couch either no it's
terrible not a good catch musk feels
like all the overtime is paying off and
now he says the model three line is back
on track and we're able to unlock some
of the critical things about holding us
back from reaching 2,000 cars a week but
since then we've continued to do 2,000
cars a week do you think that this is
sustainable this page is sustainable
yeah
rule number 27 be a doer when you first
told me that you were thinking about
tunnels and I must tell you about that
years ago okay it's like a long time ago
like I thought you were joking
yeah it was I was joking but it's not
because of some epiphany that I had one
day driving on the 405 that's how it
gets called translates and I was talking
four tunnels for years and years for
probably five years or four years at
least whenever I'd give a talk and
people would ask me about what
opportunities you d see in the world I'd
say tunnels can someone please build
tunnels so after four or five years of
begging people to build tunnels and
still no tunnels I was like okay I wanna
build a tunnel
like maybe a missing something here so
yes I was like basically talking feels
ears or tunnels for several years and
then said well let's find out what it
takes to bullet tunnel and never so
started digging a tunnel I wanted to
start the tunnel from where I could see
it from my office that SpaceX it so
stuff I said well let's just cobble for
part of the parking lot across the road
so I can see if it's if anything's
happening or not and then we named our
first boring machine Godot because I
kept waiting for it and no it came
finally did and and regret it going and
never making good progress
rule number 28 don't fear fear too much
what motivations that people need to
harness to try to make change as opposed
to just reading about change and that's
not supposed to be an easy question oh
it's it's this well like I said I think
if you if you study engineering and you
figure out how to design new things then
it's relatively easy to start a company
you just need to get a few like-minded
people with you and and then focus on
creating a prototype for compelling
prototype as soon as possible and then
that you know there's there's a strong
venture capital industry in this country
that will give you funding to take
things to the next level and that that's
all there's to it and you might you know
tried a few times my veil may not
succeed but I think sometimes people
fear fear starting a company too much
you know to say really what's the worst
that could go wrong you know kind of
starve to death you know you're not
gonna die of exposure
what's worse things go wrong rule number
29 push the limits how do you come with
this idea actually
sometime they're pushing the human limit
you are always pushing the human limit
why well
when I think about what's what
technology solution is necessary in
order to achieve the particular goal and
then try to make as much progress in
that direction as possible I think the
being a multi-planet species being out
there among the stars is important for
the long-term survival of humanity and
that's one reason kind of like life
insurance for life collectively
life as we know it but then the part
that I find personally most motivating
is that it creates a sense of adventure
and it makes people excited about the
future now if you consider two futures
one where we are forever confined to it
until eventually something terrible
happens or another future where we are
up there on many planets maybe even
going beyond the solar system I think
that second version is incredibly
exciting and inspiring and they need to
be reasons to get up in the morning you
know life can't just be about solving
problems otherwise what's the point it's
gotta be things that people find
inspiring and make life worth living
rule number 30 have fun
[Music]
come with me when moombas hits the sky
[Music]
you'll walk with me along the biome boy
okay all together now my little bugger
smile
my little buttercup where do you stay
awhile
won't we stay why movies me to the sky
and you and I walk bye-bye all bye
well this is really winning rule number
31 have a high pain tolerance there's a
friend of mine has got a great saying
about creating a company which is
creating turnable the company and have
it succeed is like eating glass and
staring into the abyss so I mean what
tends to happen is it's sort of quite
exciting for the first several months of
starting a company and then then reality
sets in things don't go as well as
planned customers aren't signing up the
technology of the part isn't working as
well as you thought and and then can
that concerns be compounded by a
recession and it could be very very
painful for several years so I think
frankly starting a company you know I
would advise people to have a high pain
tolerance
rule number thirty to generate
word-of-mouth how aside from making
great products how do you get people
excited about Tesla there's a lot of
people I know and that I talked to who
are just intrigued and interested and
excited about Tesla as a company the
thing that really focus on at Tesla is
like really put all the money into and
attention into trying to make the
product as compelling as possible so
because I think that the really the way
to sell any product is through word of
mouth so if a warrant somebody gets the
car they really like it they and
actually the key is like to have a
product that people love and journal
people that if that a party or toward
friends whatever you'll talk about the
things that you love but if you just
like something it's okay you're not
gonna care that much but if you've got
reactions from the highs and the lows
really I'm gonna you're gonna talk you
know and and then that'll jerec word of
mouth and that's basically how our sales
have grown like we don't we're not
spending money on advertising or
endorsements or and it's anywhere like
fives our card they just water because
they they like the car and you know it's
like it's genuine
rule number 33 use your own money as if
to happened you sold
and it bought the McLaren II and if I'm
not mistaken you would you invested most
of that money into your next your next
venture
XCOM that's right so yeah most of the
funds went into x-com which was later
renamed PayPal that worked out pretty
well it worked out pretty well but
looking at looking back on it would
because you put a lot of your eggs in
that basket would you advise
entrepreneurs to roll the bones quite
the way you do yeah absolutely I think
so I think I think I think it's worth
investing your own capital in what you
do I don't believe in the sort of other
people's money thing you know I think if
you're not willing to put your own
assets at stake then you shouldn't ask
other people to do that
to do that rule number 34 ignore the
competition well we don't think too much
about what board competitors are doing
yeah just because I think it's important
to be just focused on making the best
possible products you know it's sort of
maybe analogous to what this about you
know if you're in a canoe if you're if
you're in a race it's a don't worry
about what how the other what the other
runners are doing you just run
rule number 35 find your drive of 47
what is the likelihood that you
personally will go tomorrow it's 70%
you've recently made never breakthroughs
that I but that I'm just really fired up
about and when does that happen in our
lifetime yeah yeah I'm talk about moving
there so it's like if you get the price
per ticket maybe around a couple hundred
thousand dollars this could be an escape
hatch for rich people know if your
probability of dying amaz is much higher
than earth really the Africa of Mars
would be like Shackleton's after going
to the Antarctic it's gonna be hard as a
good chance of death going in a little
can through deep space you might land
successfully once you land successfully
there will be a mat you'll be working
nonstop to both the base series you're
not much time for leisure and once you
get there even after knew all the
is very harsh environment to use a good
chance to die there we think you can
come back but we're not sure now's that
sound like an escape hatch for rich
people and yet you would unhesitatingly
cup you know there's lots feel like
climb mountains you know why the climb
mountains because people die on my
diverse little time they're like doing
it for the challenge
rule number 36 persevere when did it
occur to you that zip to might be a
success well I mean when we first
started out I think our ambitions were
really quite quite low it was really to
make enough money to pay the rent yeah
we got a visa that's money that was yeah
I thought we thought it was all over
then yeah it was pretty crazy I mean
when we start out at 95 we're literally
at the beginning we had one computer
which would be the web server during the
day and and then at night I'd program on
it and and we'd sleep in the office yeah
we couldn't afford to - yeah Department
it was cheaper to rent the office than
to rent an apartment so we just rented
the office and stepped in the office and
showered at the yy-yeah and me the worst
part was eating at jack-in-the-box three
times yeah yeah man this I'll see it's
really difficult to get food at Palo
Alto after like 10:00 p.m.
it's like jack-in-the-box and a few
other options we rotate it through the
jack and it looks menu through the end
of 95 word that's essentially were just
sleeping in the office and chairing the
YMCA and then and around the end of
ninety five is where Netscape went
public and and then whether or not
somebody knew what the internet was they
knew that you could make money on the
internet somehow or even if it's only on
the greater fool theory so when we went
and talked to venture capitalists in
early 96 there was a much greater
interest in what we were doing in fact
around closed and like maybe a week or
something it's crazy yeah we went from
sleeping in the office to people
throwing me at the game this is a
financial crowd so you guys see these
numbers every day but for us who here
will give you three million dollars yeah
Oh extremely we thought they were crazy
why would they do that
it was literally people are insane they
obviously do not realize we're sleeping
in the office in fact when they when
they did fund us they realized that we
were illegal immigrants well a gray area
yeah illegal immigrants we were sleeping
in the office we didn't have a car we
had one car with the wheel kept falling
off but actually yeah the wheel that
actually fall off the car
yes exact and an adventurer kept us
actually bought us cars yeah well like I
gave us 40 grand there's 40 grand to go
buy cars which at the time was more
money than we ever seen rule number 37
make products people love advice I'd
give to people starting company to
entrepreneurs in general is really focus
on making a product that your customers
love and it's so rare that you can buy a
product and and you love the product
when you when you bought it the this is
this is there are very few things that
fit into that category and if you if you
can come up with something like that
your business will be successful for
sure
rule number 38 be willing to make
sacrifices well I mean Tesla really
faced this fear threat threat of death
due to the model 3 production ramp
essentially the company was bleeding
money like crazy and and just if we
didn't solve these problems in a very
short period of time we would die and
was extremely difficult to solve them
how close to death
did you found we're within single inch
of weeks 22 hours a day I think what
helped me I was working answer seven
days a week sleeping in the factory
worked away from the I worked in the
paint shop general assembly body shop
you ever worry about yourself imploding
like it's just yeah absolutely
no one should put this many hours into
work this is not good you feel should
not work this hard I don't look they
should not do this it was very painful
painful in what sense it's because my
hurts my brain and my heart hurts this
is not recommended for anyone I just did
it because if I didn't do it
and Tesla good chess house would die
rule number 39
great team you need a team around you to
deliver a lot of idea how do you choose
your team be somewhat well I suppose
honestly that it tends to be gut feel
more than anything else so when I
interview somebody the mind of your
question is always the same it's just I
said tell me the story of your life and
and the decisions that you made a long
way and why you made them and then if
and it and also tell me about some of
the most difficult problems you worked
on and how you solved them and that that
question I think is very important
because the people that really solve the
problem they know exactly how they
solved it they know the little details
and the people that pretend it to solve
the problem they can maybe go one level
and then they get stuff rule number
forty have fun yeah we're gonna look at
some memes right yes and say things that
are say funny things about I think we
rate them oh we rate them okay that's a
review and then they were reviewing and
out of ten horse okay I mean there's
some good memes here is this the first
one I believe so okay yeah spoon is just
a small bowl on a stick used to eat from
a larger bowl
he's earnestly presence in Congress and
you can see you can see how how how easy
it would be to just replace that text
and yeah anything you want there it's
almost as though he wasn't saying that
so yeah I rate this out of what's the
scale one to ten yeah is it one to ten
oh five I guess yeah six maybe maybe
it's a yeah range it's a mid range mean
yeah I don't think this one's got legs
also it's kind of tipping into the
political area which is like who needs
it you know if I get off my lawn
get up my line okay I'll bump it up so I
give it a sensation Madagascar and gas
car oh I see so you love you love
Madagascar because it's just a such a
heartwarming wonderful film
but then gas car you're like what I've
actually never seen this movie so you've
never seen no I guess it's lovely MERS I
refuse to watch any movie with the word
gas car in it everything is sex but how
do you feel about it is that trippy -
like for real it does a meme of with you
in it
are you sort of like what the hell yeah
alright have you gotten over that and
you're just like yeah well I mean this
past a couple years have been
particularly last year was meme city
meme City yeah main city and a lot of
memes okay now this is this is a proper
quandary okay okay would you step on
Stuart little for 18 billion dollars I
love that poor any Photoshop it's like
it's like it's like they just they got a
gray color and just erased whatever the
hell yeah you kid the only sentient
Mouse or is it sentient or sentient
sessioned sentient say I've always said
sentient I've said sentient sentient
sentient or sentient that post at all
who is that guy that's me oh my god is
that a weird combination of you and this
is a real this is a is this a real tweet
no that's a funny meme that's funny one
you could apply it not only to you but
to other celebrities and people so yeah
I think that's a funny meme okay
all right give it up it could be it
could be just like a dumb drawing it
could be any good it could be so many
wonderful things I give us I say hey
yeah it's a solid eight oh this is
this is so meta me laughing up the idea
of me laughing at me
[Laughter]
rule number 41 have a strong why the
president's first space policy directed
to me was go to the man and the wording
air is sustainable reusability is
fundamental the if you've got a fully
reusable vehicle will cost a 100 times
less for flight than an expendable
vehicle I have to Darrell about money at
all but I do care of us becoming
spacefaring civilization yeah and I do
though that if we don't actually pull
enough reusability will not happen and
so that's why that's the only reason I
actually won one money at all what I
really want to see is you know I'm gonna
face on moon on the moon permanently
occupied human based on the moon and us
building a city on Mars that's like I
can see the baby beginning of that
before I die I'll die happy rule number
42
don't be your failure we got to try to
create an electric car company but it
wasn't as though in creating these
companies that we thought that we would
be successful I thought that the most
likely outcome was failure but but it
was still worth doing even though the
odds of success were low in fact in full
force for SpaceX the originally what I
started doing was not creating a rocket
company but but actually was gonna do a
small mission to Mars which was just a
philanthropic mission where we would
send a small green house with seeds and
dehydrated gel in the wood
upon landing hydrate the gel and you'd
have this cool picture of green plants
on a red background and the public tends
to respond to precedents and
superlatives so this will be the first
life on Mars where this that life's ever
traveled and you have this great money
shot of green plants on a red background
and so I thought that would get people's
attention so but but the expectation for
that was was no return
so the expectant get any you know we'll
just spend the money on that and it
wouldn't wouldn't happen
rule number 43 use physics principles in
your thinking and the way I tend to view
problems this is from it from a physics
standpoint and I think I think physics
is good analytical framework
and one of the key things in physics is
to reason from first principles this is
contrary to the way most human reasoning
takes place which is by analogy
reasoning from first principles just
means that you figure out what are the
fundamentals what are the fundamental
truths or or things that are pretty
people are pretty sure of fundamental
truths and and can you build up to a
conclusion from from that are uniform
those principles and and then certainly
if you come up with some idea and it
appears to violate one of those
fundamental truths and you're probably
wrong or you should get a really big
prize or something like that so this may
seem like I don't know maybe it may seem
sort of obvious when it's explained but
it's actually not what people do you it
reasoning my analogies is helpful
because it's a shortcut
yeah and it's and it's mostly correct
but but it tends to be most incorrect
when you're dealing with new things
because it's hard to analogize to
something really new rule number 44 make
sacrifices well I mean Tesla really
faced the sphere threat threat of death
due to the model 3 production ramp
essentially the company was bleeding
money like crazy and and just if we
didn't solve these problems in a very
short period of time we would die and
was extremely difficult to solve them
how close to death did you come
well yeah everything single digit weeks
22 hours a day like what I mean I was
working a so seven days a week sleeping
in the factory
worked away from the I worked in the to
the paint shop general assembly body
shop you ever worry about yourself
imploding like it just yeah absolutely
no one should put the spinny hours into
work this is not good people should not
work this hard I don't look they should
not do this it was very painful painful
in what sense it's because my hurts my
brain in my heart rule or 45 take risks
he started with a much smaller rod it's
often one
and was your goal at that point when we
started with pumpkin one to get to the
point where we had nine it felt good not
without your overhead line when I
started SpaceX I only thought goes maybe
in the 10% chance of getting someone to
opens I do not really think that this
would happen
this is for sure a dream come true
but I meant anything about rockets and I
was they are going to keep it here of
space a since day one and I don't hear
anything that Rockets which is why the
first three rockets failed
okay and then so the first three valve
in one's for space sector of failures
yes and then tell me about the fourth
one so I had actually only had enough
money for even three flights so that no
more money that through nice
the teams that are proudly and we put
together a tough spare price to pay to
do a fourth launch and that fourth was
successful and
and you know what what would have happen
if it wasn't successful oh really SpaceX
for tonight so we would not be here
right now at this moment getting ready
to launch fruit dragon to the Internet
rule number 46 asked the right questions
when you were in college developing
these skills you want to do some things
that were of benefit to humanity that
why why did you think that well because
not everyone does ya know I guess it was
sort of a existential crisis of like
what does it all mean and what's the
mini you know what's the meaning of life
and there's 3 a.m. over a beer or this
was probably goes back to high school I
guess I don't to give a lavoris the long
answer but I was sort of a dark
childhood it wasn't good probably
partially brought on but by reading some
of the fluff is like don't ever read
Schopenhauer Nietzsche if you're 14
that's it's not good now or Iran either
yeah yeah so it's just trying to find
figure out what you know what as well
mean and actually when I read The
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy I think
it's a great work philosophy that sort
of highlight at the point that very
often the issue is understanding what
questions to ask and if you can properly
frame the question then the answer is
the easy part
so I thought things that expand the
scope and scale of human consciousness
and allow us to better ask questions and
you know and and and achieve greater
enlightenment those are good things and
so that's sort of what can we do that's
gonna most likely lead to that outcome
rule number 47 disrupt the industry back
in 95 they weren't very many people on
the internet and certainly nobody was
making any money at all most people
thought the internet was gonna be a fad
a year ago must sold his software
company zip2 which enabled newspapers to
publish online for four hundred million
dollars cash receiving cash is cash I
mean those are just a large number of
fan Frank
so this is an ATM what we're gonna do is
transform the traditional banking
industry
I do not fit the picture of a banker
raising 50 million dollars is a matter
of making a series of phone calls and
the money is there
I sunk the great majority of my net
worth interacts calm which is the new
banking and mutual funds company on the
internet that I've started I think XCOM
could absolutely be a multi-billion
dollar bonanza because if you look at
the industry that X is pursuing
it's the biggest center of the world
economy and what you've got going on
with the Internet is it's basically like
an earthquake where the epicenter is
Silicon Valley and it's it's shaking up
the whole world
rule number 48 have people you admire
you've been compared to Henry Ford
Richard Branson you know Steve Jobs who
do you compare yourself to I mean I
don't really compare myself to anyone I
mean it's not with a certain people that
I've learned from history that I think
are you know I think a great certainly
many of the scientists and engineers and
buttery figures and so forth and like
I'm a big big fan of Anna Franklin you
know there's a scientist and sort of
thinker and get me who's kind of guys
who did it did what needed to be done
you know so I what guys like that I
write wouldn't say I compare myself in
any way but I certainly admire them you
number 49 pushed the frontier I think
part of the problem with the reason
people aren't as excited about space is
that we haven't been pushing the
frontier as much and so you can only you
can only watch the same movie so many
times in it before it gets a little
boring and you know in in this in the
60s and early 70s we're really pushing
the frontier of human spaceflight and
and out so that those land landing on
the moon is regarded as one of the
greatest achievements of humanity of
arguably of life itself and even though
only a handful of people went to the
moon vicariously we all went there well
at least I wasn't alive at the time so
but retrospectively
and you know and it was it was just one
of those really inspiring things that I
think made everyone glad to be a you
know human you know it's like the things
that we were you know if they're bad
things you man ideas and they're there
are good things and it's one of the good
things and I do think it's important
that that we have these inspiring things
that you make you glad to get up in the
morning and and that that's glad to be a
member of the human race and we need to
we need to push that that bed front here
so and I think the great goal we should
be trying to pursue is trying to make
life human make make life multiplanetary
so to establish a self-sustaining
and growing civilization on another
planet Mars being the only realistic
possibility and and I think that would
just be one of the greatest things
humanity could ever try to do and rule
number 50 the last one before a very
special bonus clip is make things happen
from the first explorers who ventured
off our planet to those who have risked
their lives and pursued to furthering
our understanding of the universe the
astronauts and engineers behind the u.s.
space program have spent decades
advancing space technology but building
rockets was expensive by the early 2000s
the u.s. space program was struggling
an emission tomorrow's was hard to
imagine Space Shuttle spreads its wings
one final time for the start of a
Sentimental Journey into history it was
then that a young entrepreneur had a
revolutionary idea
[Music]
with SpaceX what we're trying to do is
achieve a huge advancement in rocket
technology if you look at rocket
technology it actually got worse over
time in 1969 we were able to go to the
moon and then with the Space Shuttle we
were only able to go to low-earth orbit
and then with a spatial went away and
then we weren't able to go to orbit from
the United States so like that's a
negative trend line it's not like you
can extrapolate that trend line into the
future and it gets good it's a trend
line to zero so if it's not gonna come
from the government
then it's got to come from a private
company now I have a special bonus it
from Elon Musk and how to ask great
questions that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that is time for the
three point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
an action here we go question number one
what difficulty do you have right now
that you just need to persevere through
number two what's the fear that you fear
too much and number three where do you
need to be more of an adventurer and if
you promise to take action after
watching this video we don't just watch
videos anymore we do something after
watching them give me a hashtag believed
down the comments make that promise to
yourself and then get to work innovation
comes from questioning the way things
have been done before yeah and if in the
education system you're taught not to do
that that will inhibit entrepreneurship
being able to question what you're being
taught being able to yeah I mean just
you know saying well is there a better
way yeah yeah to ask that question if
you want to learn how to be the next
Elon Musk check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
the challenge for entrepreneurs is to
say well what's the difference between
really believing in new ideals and
sticking sticking to them versus
pursuing some unrealistic